[Music]
on this Wednesday night Landmark climate
deal or Litany of loopholes the
agreement at cop 28 to transition away
from fossil fuels how can it be done
Israel's prime minister dismisses
International pressure for a
humanitarian ceasefire as heavy rain
makes life more dire for people in Gaza
and Canada's support for a ceasefire
ignites new political Rifts in Ottawa
road to recovery I really see it as uh a
privilege Israelis still volunteering to
help sick Palestinians get treatment in
Israeli hospitals and reinvigorating the
Heart of Manitoba's Capital this project
is literally economic reconciliation the
unique game plan between the owner of an
NHL team and 34 First
Nations global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us it didn't go as far as
calling for a phase out of the use of
fossil fuels but the final agreement at
the UN climate Summit in Dubai is being
hailed as historic if only because the
words fossil fuels are finally being
mentioned we have language on fossil
fuel in our final agreement for the
first time
ever nearly 200 countries agreed to
transition away from coal natural gas
and oil the biggest producers of
greenhouse gas emissions phasing out was
a step too far for Big Oil exporters
like Saudi Arabia and this was a
compromise an important Milestone is
what climate activists and former US
vice president Al Gore calls it but it's
also the bare minimum We need he says
and is long overdue he and others warn
of the influence of countries whose
economies depend on oil and gas
production is on the rise and it's not
clear at all what the timeline is to
transition away Heather yuck West has
our top story on the agreement and the
reaction cop 28 has ended with a deal
and Canada's environment Minister says
he's pleased this outcome is Monumental
Steven gibo said on social media we've
reached a global consensus to secure a
clean energy transition away from fossil
fuels that's a really big step forward
for an International Conference like
this so while it uh the final wording
may not have been quite as strong as as
Canada was advocating for that we would
uh hope to see it's it's still a big
step forward what Canada and more than
100 other nations had wanted was a full
fossil fuel phase out instead the deal
calls for a transition that would get
the world to net zero emissions by 2050
so the industry has been working towards
this for a long time um the real
question becomes how can it be done
Canada's oil sand Consortium the
pathways Alliance says it was pleased to
see the deal recognized the role carbon
capture and other Technologies can play
towards a future that can include more
oil and gas whether we end up with 25 or
100 million barrels per day in 2050
there will still be significant demand
it said and we should continue to meet
that Demand with Canadian Oil this year
the highest number of fossil fuel
lobbyists ever were at cop over
2456 fossil fuel lobbyists came to
essentially bring these negotiations off
the rails and weaken the final outcome
climate scientists have argued that a
future with even Abad fossil fuels may
not be enough to keep the Earth from
warming Beyond 1 and A2 degrees but
Alberta's Premier disagrees I am greatly
encouraged by the success in pushing
back against the voices of those
obsessed with accelerating the phase out
Danielle Smith said the deal to
transition away from fossil fuels seen
as a win for those pushing to keep the
industry going for decades to come
Heather urick West Global News
Calgary Israel's prime minister says
nothing will stop his war against Hamas
including International pressure
Benjamin Netanyahu spoke to military
commanders a day after at least nine
Israeli soldiers were killed in Gaza one
of the deadliest days for the Israeli
military since their operation began in
Gaza heavy rain and cold temperatures
are adding to the despair especially for
those forced into makeshift camps most
gin have been displaced from their homes
tens of thousands of them are trying to
survive in flimsy shelters near Rafa as
far south as they can go and food warm
clothing and supplies are increasingly
hard to find for 68 days Gaza has been
under siege and every day the
humanitarian crisis deepens Crystal
ganing Reports and a warning some of the
images in her story are
distressing it's a delivery received
with open arms the hospital resupply by
UNICEF however took place under tense
conditions we focus on Bano newborn and
child health we know that there are many
cases of of injuries but but we also
focus on the other areas of pregnant
women the fighting will continue until
victory until Hamas is annihilated says
the Israeli Prime Minister his words
follow not only a wave of International
pressure but also one of the deadliest
days for Israeli soldiers since the
ground offensive
began on Tuesday 10 Israeli soldiers
were killed including nine from the gani
Brigade involved in an operation in
Northern Gaza two senior commanders were
killed that
day for those in Gaza grief is clashing
with the changing season heavy rain wind
and falling temperatures are making life
in displacement camps that much more
intolerable Beyond fetching clean water
buckets of sand are gathered to build up
the ground around their homes crafted
out of blankets and scraps of
plastic as you can see it was torn apart
we tried to fix it it was torn and the
water fell on us we were drenched in
rain right before the rains hit the
United Nations described the situation
on the ground as apocalyptic for those
trying to survive it all the suffering
is
endless I can't see a peaceful solution
I can't see one I hope to God that there
will be a peaceful solution hope in the
face of grim reality Crystal ganing
Global News London Canada's decision to
vote in favor of a UN resolution calling
for for an immediate humanitarian
ceasefire and the unconditional release
of all the hostages is being both
praised and condemned Canada voted with
the majority of countries at the UN but
there was no condemnation of Hamas in
that resolution and that doesn't sit
well with everyone David Aken is
following reaction from Ottawa David
well Donna this division within the
government caucus existed before the UN
vote you remember some liberal MPS many
of the Muslim or representing writings
with large Arabic populations well they
had written an open letter to the Prime
Minister asking for Canada to press for
a full ceasefire and those MPS they were
pleased this week to see that shift in
the government's position I don't think
this anti-israeli this the benefit for
for the benefit on both side Israel and
Palestinian as a mother I cannot sleep
at night and as I think all of most of
us as parents I think we have to play a
leadership role to make sure that we
protect the innocent civilians we are
alarmed at the diminishing safe space
for civilians but the UN vote has now
upset many other liberals those for
example who are Jewish or have large
Jewish populations in their writing
Montreal MP Anthony housefather is one
of those an unconditional ceasefire
simply puts Israel as one who has
International obligations as having to
lay down arms and Kamas which is a
terrorist organization that has no
obligation to follow International rules
will'll just do what it did again and I
I can't live with that so is Winnipeg MP
Ben Carr I'm a liberal and it's okay for
me to uh at times question or disagree
or Ponder the positions on certain
issues that my party has taken just
curious how you're reacting indeed
several liberal MPS said the public
airing of these disagreements is the way
democracy should work and is a sign of
strength we have a tradition between
Muslim caucus members and Jewish caucus
members every year we get together and
have Christmas dinner we have a
wonderful relationship amongst our
caucus I can tell you that the mood in
caucus is very strong um look we are a
diverse caucus we represent the
diversity in Canada now as for the Prime
Minister he reminded his caucus that
Canada's call for a ceasefire also came
with a call for Hamas to lay down its
arms and for Hamas to release all
hostages Donna all right David Aken in
Ottawa thank
you ceas fire now ceas fire now people
demanding a ceasefire down a freeway in
downtown Los Angeles this morning
protesters linked arms and blocked
traffic for about an hour 75 people were
arrested it was organized by a group
called if not now a group of American
Jews who want elected officials to call
for a lasting ceasefire and an end to us
support for Israel's war the group has
held a number of disruptive protests
across the us since October 7th in
Ukraine a barrage of Russian missiles
pounded keev today injuring at least 53
people it is the second major assault on
Ukraine Capital this week the missile
severely damaged homes and a children's
hospital people streamed out onto the
streets to assess the damage Ukraine's
president was in Oslo today urging
Nordic leaders to continue giving
military and economic aid to his country
Global News has learned a second
suspected senior Iranian official may be
deported from Canada no information
about the man's alleged role in the
regime has been released the immigration
and Refugee board is trying to determine
if there are sufficient grounds for
deportation under Canadian sanctions
today the defense minister Bill Blair
said certain individuals involved with
the Islamic revolutionary guard Corp are
involved in
terrorism when individuals have been
involved in activity that would make
them ineligible to be in this country
we'll do everything we can to keep them
out and when they do get into this
country we'll do everything we can to
remove them you can read the full story
about this on our website globalnews.ca
global national the defense minister
also had an update on culture change
within the Department of Defense and the
Canadian Armed Forces Bill Blair says 17
of 48 recommendations made by former
Supreme Court Justice Louise arbore have
now been completed the government will
also be abolishing the use of the term
sexual misconduct and will more clearly
Define sexual assault we believe that by
providing a clear definition of sexual
assault in line with the criminal code
we will be better positioned to act when
incidents occur and to respond in a more
trauma informed way our Bo's review
examined how to eradicate sexual
harassment and misconduct from the
military reconciliation and
revitalization coming up how co-owners
of an NHL team and dozens of First
Nations hope to inject new life into
Winnipeg's downtown
core Tesla is recalling more than 2
million vehicles in Canada and the US to
fix a defect in its autopilot system it
follows a 2-year investigation by us US
Safety Regulators into a series of Tesla
crashes that happened when the autopilot
system was in use some of them were
deadly the recall covers more than 2
million Vehicles sold in the US and
193,000 sold in Canada models sx3 and Y
manufactured since October 2012 are
included Transport Canada says Tesla
will release an over-the-air software
update to install new safeguards many
cities are struggling to revitalize
their downtown cores and now Winnipeg is
is taking a unique approach the company
that owns the Winnipeg Jets is
collaborating with 34 Southern Manitoba
First Nations they are teaming up to
revitalize Winnipeg's Corps by
developing nearly 2 million square fet
of vacant real estate that includes the
baguer Portage Place Mall and the now
empty Hudson Bay building both not far
from the Canada Life Center where the
Jets play as Melissa rgen explains the
plans involve both economic and social
development we want to create
environment vibrant Dynamic downtown
that leads to economic growth and
improves quality of life of our people
Grand Chief Jerry Daniels shares a
common goal with a couple of very rich
businessmen Toronto billionaire David
Thompson and his business partner Mark
Chipman co-owners of the Winnipeg Jets
the southern Chiefs organization is
looking to turn this vacant Hudson Bay
building into affordable housing with
green space and Health Services while
Chipman and Thompson want to turn this
mostly empty Mall into housing with
office space and community and health
supports so why not coordinate seo's
plans for the bay and our plans for
Court's place will be far more impactful
if done in collaboration where we both
actively seek out what is good for one
another it's a natural collaboration the
building's already joined by a walkway
and outside both the Grim toll mental
health addictions and homelessness is
taking the new Hub will include much
needed community and health supports we
now see it as a social red development
plan first a real estate development
second it also represents what can
happen when the requisite level of trust
and a desire for the common good is
shared between organizations this
project is literally economic
reconciliation the revitalization plan
with support from all three levels of
government is set to start next year
with a 2027 Target for completion
Melissa origion Global News
Winnipeg calling out bad behavior still
ahead the push for anti racism policies
in Newland labrador's school
system a doctor in newfinland is calling
out racism in the small community where
he serves hundreds of patients he says
he reached a Breaking Point when his
daughter was attacked as Heidi petruk
explains a video he posted online went
viral sparking calls for action and a
change of heart this is only racism and
discre discrimination Dr gergus abar
wrote the online post after he says his
teenage daughter was attacked at school
she was crying and have some superficial
injures in her face the same day he
received this text from an unknown
number threatening harm and calling him
quote Mr black police charged a youth
with assault in connection with the
incident at the school an escalation of
what he describes as the racist bullying
his daughter has endured in the small
newand town of Lewisport since they
moved there 2 years ago the alleged
assault is the point at which he and his
wife both local Physicians thought of
packing up and leaving I tried to to
know what is what is the reaction of the
public is the public have the same point
of view that we are black we are
immigrant we are not supposed to be here
like so many rural communities Lewisport
desperately needs its local doctors his
post brought forth a flood of support a
call from the premier and a statement by
the mayor denouncing quote all forms of
racism stereotyping prejudice and
discrimination we do have to recognize
that the incident did take place and uh
we certainly don't support that we
support all families who might be
encountering these pieces or that are
struggling right now anti-racism
activists in the province say this isn't
an isolated incident some are pushing
for changes in the school system for
better prevention and intervention and
if we don't deal with his people are
going to say well we have better support
in other communities we are going to
leave is the school
board in New Found
land are able to protect our kids the
school board says it does strive to
ensure schools are safe in his latest
video post Dr Embark says he's decided
to stay in the end to ensure the board
does what's needed to make sure all
families are supported Heidi pic Global
News
Halifax so nice of you to greet us
meline I thought surely you'd still be
crushed under that house in munchkinland
land Sticks and Stones Raymond
describing your breakfast P actor Andre
Brower known as Captain Raymond Holt in
the TV comedy Brooklyn 99 he has died
after a brief illness he won two me
Awards he's being remembered as a
versatile actor he played a detective in
homicide life on the street and the
leader of a heist crew in Thief Brower
was 61 years
old next the Israeli volunteers helping
save the lives of
Palestinians
before Israel's war on Hamas
Palestinians who needed Advanced Medical
treatment often traveled to Israeli
hospitals for treatment to help with the
complicated Journey a charity called
road to recovery connects Israeli
volunteers with Palestinians who need
Transportation Canadian Vivien silver
who was killed in the October 7th
attacks was one of those drivers the
charity can no longer operate in Gaza
but volunteers are still helping
Palestinians in the West Bank Danielle
Hamin talked to some of them about what
drives them to keep
going Mahmud SAA is just a year and a
half but he knows this routine quite
well his rare genetic disorder requires
a long trip to the hospital every few
weeks and almost every
time there's a different driver at the
wheel but always an Israeli I think I
drove with you two weeks ago maybe three
hey hey hey hey hey they've asked us not
to show their faces the SAA family is
from the West Bank and is only allowed
into Israel because of mahmud's medical
appointments his Palestinian parents
cannot drive here and so they rely on
volunteers like matitiahu
sperber who tries his best to make it a
comfortable trip it's a Palestinian
music playlist on
Spotify but you like the Arab Music okay
well I I I've I've been listening to
this playlist for a long time now and I
actually like a lot of the
songs he's part of a charity called road
to
recovery I have to say that I I really
see it as uh a privilege he's one of
about a thousand volunteers who shuttle
sick Palestinians mostly children to
Israeli hospitals from the occupied West
bank and prior to October 7th from Gaza
you know it's like my mission you cannot
go go against your
mission yeah eloi is head of the charity
she's proud of her work but she's also
now very cautious in Israel now the main
main thing to say is everyone in Gaza is
Hamas and we should not help anyone
there and today I feel even sometimes
it's a bit dangerous for me talking
about what I'm I'm
doing Israeli Canadian peace activist
Vivian silver was also one of the
volunteer
drivers but was killed on the day of the
attack most of all our donations is to
donations to the charity have poured in
from all over the world but in Israel
these are the kinds of threats yel now
hears Vian silver we heard about your
volunteer it's glad what they were glad
what what happened to her and they wish
us that maybe we will go to Gaza and
they rape us and they cut us and I don't
I really don't want to talk about it was
those are fellow Israelis telling you
that back on the road to the West Bank
nothing will deter sperber who grew up
in the US Rabbi Abraham Joshua hesel who
would talk about how when he was on the
March for civil rights from Selma to
Montgomery in I think it was
1965 how he felt like he was praying
with his
feet and uh and I always enjoyed that
image and I feel that now I feel that
when I'm driving these people and and
providing this this the service for them
that I'm praying with my wheels no
lineups at the checkpoint going into
Palestinian territory it's coming out
that's usually the problem okay the day
ends with smiles and a handshake a rare
sight these
days Daniel hamam Jin Global News at the
Honan checkpoint in the West
Bank and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna FZ tonight's
your candidate is the cpkc holiday train
that's making its way through Calgary
raising money for the food bank along
the way we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at global.com
and thanks for watching hope to see you
here again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye